Jonah's the goat man
did you think that that was abusive no I
did not think it's abusive because
[__] out their goddamn [__] mind
yo they are out there God now bring up
the text because of the tech so he was
while in a little bit there you go
that's like listen he's wild a little
bit like
but he did something fire imma start
using the word boundaries for anything I
don't like oh yeah I have a boundary
where you disagree with anything I say
so if you do that then you're breaking
one of my boundaries and I can't be with
you that being said I don't think there
was a single thing that was abusive
about what he did no I think it was
abusive I was crazy insecure and like
shitty yeah he's insecure yeah but like
he says he's not saying like you can't
be a human being
like I wish you well
send your ass on Instagram I just
personally don't want you going to these
little surf dates with other men I just
personally don't want a partner that's
gonna do that and if you need to do that
you go for it I I wish you the best you
got it but I can't have that she met her
while she was doing all these things got
with her while she was doing all these
things and now that you're together
you're like now I'm not okay with all
these things
abusive bro inconvenient sure this is a
little inconvenient it's a bit more it's
not abusive but it's more than anything
so then what is it
it's just being a shitty boyfriend and
maybe like um
toxic is a word I can we can settle on
toxic I think I think that [__] is toxic
Hill don't have your ass on Instagram
you weren't when you weren't with me
that [__] worked to get me now you got
me now get your ass off Instagram simple
as that but if she's a surfer in his
pictures of her surfing you don't need
to surfing a thong
did you see shorty in a thong surfing
that's when all these girls surfing
though they're dumb
not mine not mine out there you're first
of all even if you do surfing it you
need to have a picture of you getting
back shots on [__] Instagram what you
need to have a picture of you bent over
showing the [__] thong on your ass
she's putting up a picture of her
Services Straight to Surf somebody gotta
[__] come into the water with a
camera a waterproof camera wait a minute
let me bend over on the board so you can
perfectly see the swims who are you who
are you guys what type of [__] men
are you that are gonna defend the girl
with her [__] [__] lips out on
Instagram I wouldn't get with a girl who
was a surprise
no no no you get with them and you
change them
yeah maybe he wiped her and he was like
yo you don't need work anymore I got you
but you're just dating and you can't do
what you love or whatever that's wifey
no he doesn't like her they're not
married fish
girl he's with when we were doing a
movie they together non-stop that's
that's wifey so it's in your brain for
this dumb [__] this is so gay of both
of you this is this is uh
of us and I said it's not abuse what's
toxic about it don't be dating dudes in
a thong
it's awesome
don't let your girls do this just let
you you're gonna let your girl go and
have surf dates with a guy
if my girl if she serves and I don't
surf go so so when your girl met you
right when all of our girls met us
except for y'all okay me and you when
our girls met us we was out in these
streets
that changed once we have a relationship
right yeah so [__] changes once you're
in a relationship I don't consider she's
surfing out in these streets
I'll be honest with you if you don't
want you surfing get your
[__] serving for get your [__] in
yo you can't have the cheeks covered bro
like that's a crazy we live in a world
where you can't tell your girl to cover
her [__] when she's out there in a
surfboard that's abusive to be like yo
cover your [__] when you're surfing
with men that's abuse that's toxic we
didn't we say it's not abuse it's toxic
you said it's toxic again you gay
if you're a man and you say any other
man's toxic again
and you've also want to sing to your
girl and it's just singing yeah it's
just singing yeah you cool with that
just singing yeah
the first to sing and then then you add
them 22.
I'm just saying first you say that you
attitude too
that's how it starts that's how it
starts Usher don't play podcast Usher
don't play I sure will sing your girl
out her panties bro I'm telling you it's
a problem bro you saw it happen to Keke
Palmer and she had she had dicks out
like that looking crazy
[Laughter]
[Music]
today all right so what are we doing
y'all are crazy you're gonna let your
girl surf in a thong with men
is there a female Surf Wave is it a
female wave is it a women's only way is
it is it a women's only break from 9 to
11 is only women that are there is that
it then she could wear full covered
underwear [__] up
her job dude it's not Urban Behavior
Joshua professional Surfer she wants to
be a surfer she's a surf instructor I
believe right no she teaches [__]
yoga she's a useless
[Music]
she's a useless she's a useless
from the second I saw
oh this is great she sees a lot of
pictures of Surfing bro she's angry
she's angry because she's dating surfing
bro like if this was her page before you
got with her come on son that means she
can't post no more this is pretty modest
to me I don't think come on yo
yo she's wearing a 50s bathing suit that
was fun I didn't say nothing about that
one I didn't say nothing about it that's
appropriate that's appropriate that's an
appropriate attire oh my God now go to
the other one come on yo why you need it
you you told your friend hey take this
picture of me looking on into the
distance where you see my ass cheek
hanging out my [__] bathing suit you
said take the thirst trap who are you
thirst trapping for violence y'all crazy
y'all are really crazy I can't believe
I'm talking y'all right now I truly
can't believe it I truly can't believe
it I am I honestly I know thank you so I
thought I was crazy this man crazy you
you can make Arguments for them girls to
be [__] is that what you want just like
I'm just so confused I'm so confused so
we're usually no no no
[Music]
hey no you're on vacation I'm on
vacation and you're on a boat I'm on a
boat with your shirt off with my shirt
off I've posted all these thirst traps
star straps that's cool that's cool but
can you shorty do it hell no
now ask yourself did you see him did you
see any posters
that's what I'm saying so you could be a
thought but she could 100 that's his
balance
that's life I Instagram know these rules
I can show my titties women can't show
their titties because even Zuckerberg
even most sarri knows Paul yeah deep cut
yeah we're going after the real CEO yeah
a [__] Instagram he knows a woman's
titties is different than a man's
titties ow what's different about him
you can suck all up on them titties you
can suck all about a man's titties okay
y'all are really crazy for trying to cap
for this [__] stupid behavior from
this girl she wanted to Surf like a [__]
no
we're not allowing no [__] Surfers out
here it's not gonna happen wow no I'm
not wild y'all are well that's so crazy
when we disagree you're like okay so
okay so a girl could just [__] anybody
relationship right she changed that yes
that one you should change something's
changing oh so there's certain things
you can change yes but having your
[__] lips hanging out of a bathing
suit all you want to search
that's disgusting okay not I get your
[__] lips tucked into that little
[__] old bodybuilder baby
[Laughter]
yo the World's Strongest Man bathing
suit from the 20s that's the type of
bathing suit you need to wear that's
some respect and she's actually good if
she was just one of these doctors like
Oh I'm a surfer but she just goes out
there to take cute pictures that's
something different but she's actually
nice with it yeah so like she does this
she never got stuck underwater yeah I
think that's what I think that's not
what he's mad about it he's like never
look this good surfing she pretty good
pretty good
I'm telling you Society needs to wait
listen we got to go back to the Ottoman
Empire bro what we need to do is go back
to the Ottoman Empire we need some rules
we need a little bit more structure and
organization you're acting crazy because
you would not allow none of this [__]
from your wife son I didn't meet my wife
as a surfer what does that have that to
do with anything she wants to do what
she loves surfing he's saying no surfing
I'm sorry did you think marriage is
about doing what you love
what the [__] is wrong with you Akasha
it's about sacrificing the things you
love more than anything he's mad at you
hanging out with her female friends
please go hang out your female friends
leave me alone not female friends male
friends no he said female friends too no
surf dates no hang out with your little
[__] [__]
listen listen you don't want your girl
hanging out with [__] buckets you you
don't want that let's say your wife had
a bunch of [__] [__] bucket friends do
you want her fraternizing with those
[__] disgusting holes
that's a fact and if she did you would
have an issue with it I'll be honest I
got an issue with most of my wife's
friends and they ain't even [__]
I do have an issue I got the [__]
laser on all y'all [__] up one time it's
done even the games
what about the gay friends
bro the gays you good the gays are good
maybe a little touch friendly though
[Music]
the other way
let's see how verse y'all are yeah you
gotta test all your girls friends bro
it's so funny because if there's an
undercover [__] straight in the game
mix that's the problem bro can't do it
that's what I'm saying you your girl
your girl she has a lot of family right
your wife she got a lot of family yeah
that don't count bro
she can have [__] bucket friends
oh
but that was all cat because she does I
had to I had to um agree to at least
thongs because she's from Spain and they
go topless over that and she's like what
the [__] yeah you say yo when when we in
Spain then you do it yeah but we in
America if we go to the beaches out here
like if we go to Miami some beaches here
just wrapped a little skirt around here
no no no I will say this so she's like I
can't be comfortable on the beach
because of what you're uncomfortable
with and I'm like yeah no
that is a cultural thing and I actually
don't think it's that bad
to be honest I don't think it's that bad
if you guys are comfortable with it but
if that was something you were really
uncomfortable with you were just like
hey it just makes me feel insecure I see
all these guys looking at you and like
it makes me want to like protect you and
then I feel like I have to do something
physical with these guys just it doesn't
allow me to relax on the beach like it
just makes it my whole Beach experience
really awful I bet you she would go I
don't want your Beach experience to be
awful just for like three more inches of
fabric of course I'll do it yeah that's
a therapized way to say it you don't
think he started with that no no of
course he started you think that's the
first text
she's a loony bucket
it's for my surfboard I'm gonna go wax
my surfboard hey hey look at these dogs
that quack for my surfboard yeah wax up
my surfboard I'm just gonna know what
the [__] going on surfing with dudes
is crazy bro
there's only dudes out there why why you
pick a man's sport
stop picking man hobbies bro pick a girl
hobby shopping you was doing gymnastics
what about a volleyball backflip that's
dramatic that's a girl's book you out
here showing up for the girlies bro what
would you do with that what if you got a
gymnast
about that
apologize I was attracting too many
[__] with that backflip that I did I
was thinking I was attractive
[Laughter]
you [__]
I feel like you shut the [__] up